[Musik]
richtig
hallo herzlich willkommen so sullivan
heute gibt es wieder einen richtig
tollen klassiker ich mache nämlich eine
malakhov torte sicher der eine oder
andere schon davon gehört
die torte wird auf den meisten regionen
auch als charlotte bezeichnet ich glaube
die österreichische variante ist die
malakhov torte und zwar für eine torte
ich habe hier einen luft boden mit einer
bis kitschig und auch mit ganz vielen
richtig schönen löffelbiskuits sich
selbst gespritzt habe die füllung
besteht aus einer art bayrisch creme das
heißt eine creme mit eiern die dann
gebunden wird und meist mit platine
verarbeitet wird
ich zeige euch heute eine variante die
mit seiner klinik gefunden wird und eine
variante die mit agar gebunden wird als
mit den pflanzlichen geliermittel ich
muss am anfang dazu sagen dass die torte
ein bisschen aufwendiger ist das heißt
für eine sonntags torte ist es eine
richtig tolle torte ihr müsst euch auf
jeden fall die zeit nehmen geduld haben
und dann klappt auch alles wirklich
wunderbar ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal
an mit der mürbeteig und seid euch mal
kurz mit blut hatten
für den mittagstisch wird sich vom
zucker 80 kalte butter etwas von ihrer
extrakt 120 kaum mehr eine chance und
ein eigens zuerst einmal nämlich jetzt
die kalte butter und zucker und ich
mache es dann selbst in der
küchenmaschine beim ist immer ganz
wichtig dass die zutaten kalt sind und
dass derzeit auch schnell verarbeitet
wird und am besten ohne hände damit er
eben auch schon kalt bleibt
und falls ihr keine küchenmaschine oder
ein handfunkgerät habt könnt ihr auch
immer gerne so einen teig für hacker
nehmen
damit geht es auch ganz gut oder zum
beispiel auch den fall mit einem messer
hatten
kommt noch die restlichen zutaten
betreiben also eigelb melancholie und
[Musik]
natürlich auch ein bisschen neuen exakt
und dann wird er zeigt ganz schnell
verknetet
[Musik]
derzeit gut durchgeknetet und jetzt gebe
ich ihnen auf die arbeitsfläche und
formen dann einfach einer kugel zusammen
[Musik]
und diese mini zeigt opel kommt es in
einer minute und die drücke ich jetzt
nach so wird der teig eben viel
schneller kalt und den teig kann ich
dann etwa eine halbe stunde lang öl und
euch in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
zutat für den vip zeigen für den disput
brauche ich 61 eine prise salz zucker 6
145 gramm zucker 140 gramm mehl und
etwas von dem extrakt nämlich zuerst
eiweiße bekommt jetzt in meister in
meine saubere und fettfreie schütteln da
gebe ich jetzt dabei das so und findet
erst noch steif geschlagen
[Musik]
und dabei ist der eisberg kommt noch der
poker mit aussuchen und dann wird das
ganze noch mal durch die komplette
mission streiten
der schnee ist schön fest
da kommt jetzt der trend dann der
restliche zucker etwas von den extrakt
[Musik]
da das schulwesen wieder dazu und die
masse wie dies in etwa 56 minuten krems
geführt
[Musik]
die maße schön dick cremig wie ihr sehen
könnt
jetzt brauche ich die küchenmaschine
nicht mehr sondern der beste ist mit dem
schneebesen verhallt verwirrt ich jetzt
dazu und hebelt es mit dem schneebesen
vorsichtig unter
damit gebe ich noch den eischnee unter
und dann wird der bisher richtig schön
locker
die masse finde ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel damit ein loch töne dran
mit elf millimetern durchmesser einfach
eine ganz große rolle denn damit laden
zuerst krebs gespritzt
und dann ist ein vampir und auf der
rückseite haben schon linien
aufgezeichnet
mit fünf zentimetern abstand dann
nochmal 13 sie mit der abstand dann eben
wieder 15
das heißt ich hätte sie lassen sich
einfach in 5 cm länger drauf steht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und damit die level wird auch schon
farbe bekommen
gestreut wird mit etwas puderzucker und
ich brauch später insgesamt etwa 40
stück aber ich mache immer ein paar mehr
das machen noch mal ein halbes gleich so
dass ich etwa 60 stück habe einfach um
sicher zu gehen dass ich später genug ab
[Musik]
und da kommen jetzt in den backofen
dabei heißluft 190 grad
damit sei einfach schön trocken werden
und die feuchtigkeit entweichen kann
die einzel pleite also egal woran teils
packen damit die feuchten noch
herauskommt mit dem bug löffel
dazwischen und dann für etwa fünf bis
sechs minuten
[Musik]
die restliche masse habe ich jetzt in
meinem bett bringen eingeführt mit 24
zentimetern durchmesser damit ist auch
schon mit zusätzlicher bestreut und
kommt dann in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 200 grad ober unterhitze zu etwas
zehn minuten
als nächstes ging es jetzt um den
mürbeteig den habe ich jetzt noch auf
durchgeknetet und kann ihn jetzt aus
meiner auerbach wohl hier einfach
ausfallen
damit der teig schön gleichmäßig ist
nämlich mein körper mit drei millimetern
stärke und wollten jetzt aus und bat ihn
dann auf 24 cm durchmesser ausrollen und
da könnt ihr euch dann auch zu hilfe
einfach einen bug ring nehmen
[Musik]
und den rest passt es einfach mit den
fingern an mit schlechten tag mehrmals
mit einer gabel eindruck bleibt so
einfach scheint blatt
und so von den vorgeheizten backofen bei
200 grad ober unterhitze etwa sechs bis
acht minuten bis eine schöne farbe
bekommen hat und dann lasse ich alles ab
und würde der biscuit teelöffel biskuits
und die mappacks autositz abgekühlt
jetzt gibt mit der creme weiter die
creme dass es so eine art bayrisch creme
das heißt eine creme mit minz und mit
sahne und sie wird auch mit einer
gefunden
ich zeige euch noch kurz die zutaten für
die krähen brauche ich den gramm
gemahlene oder sechs platine
hier habe ich 400 millilitern milch 75
gramm zucker etwas man in der extrakt
eine prise salz 2 eigelb und 600
milliliter sahne
ihr fragt sich wahrscheinlich warum dem
display solutions nehme ganz um ganze
routine
auch bei dieser trainingsorte wird
gleich im topf zubereitet aber sie darf
eben eigentlich nicht kochen
bei ärger also bei das landshuter safina
ist es so die muss zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen
das kam bei der creme ist im prinzip
auch machen das heißt ich kann das
avatar mit wasser zwei minuten aufkochen
und später porträt meter zu geben werden
uns zusätzliche aufwand und ich zeige
mich einfach mal die variante mit der
statine der typische variante
ich nehme sie ihr gemahl winter sonatine
und weiß jetzt mit der milch auf das
heißt die kassieren bis den quellen des
dauert ein paar minuten gibt's hier
stehen lassen und in der zwischenzeit
hier schon mal die milch in einem topf
geben
hier kommt ein ziel das war extraklasse
für den schönen manila geschmack damit
ist als grund der zucker und die
mischung darf ich erst mal kurz
aufkochen und sobald sie gekocht nehme
ich sie vom herd herunter und geben so
ein bisschen von der milch mit diesen
eingeben
das ist schön verrühren
das mache ich jetzt deswegen damit die
eigelbe wenn ich jetzt hier einfach so
mit rein gebe nicht stoppen weil er die
milch einfach viel zu heiß ist das heißt
nämlich temperatur an
und jetzt kann ich sie zurück zur
restlichen milch geben und dann
verbindet das alles schön
ich stelle den herd herunter das heißt
auf stufe 3 etwa und freiheit ganz
langsam mit der temperatur immer höher
bis die mischung ein weg das dauert etwa
drei bis fünf minuten und währenddessen
darf er dann auch einmal aufkochen
jetzt kommt die initiative hier mit rein
und wird eingeführt unterlassene das
niemals kochen
das ist ein bisschen anders als 3 aka
aka noch fröhlich einfach so lange bis
es vollständig aufgelöst habe ich in der
zwischenzeit übrigens auch schon steif
geschlagen und die stilistin kühlschrank
eine größere schüssel um zum einen damit
ich später die sahne gut unterhalten
kann und zum anderen damit die masse
jetzt besser abkühlen kann
und falls ihr euch ein bisschen unsicher
seid ob die gelatine zum beispiel wirkt
oder auch mal dass agenten einen kleinen
teller nehmen und dafür mit eine schippe
drauf geben und diese so in den
kühlschrank stellen
und ich musste ganz kurz darauf warten
bis die masse hier etwas abkühlt das
heißt etwa lauwarm
das merkt ja auch schon doch die masse
dann ein bisschen verwirrt und dann kann
ich die sahne gleich unterheben
während die kriegen noch abkühlen kann
ich schon mal den torten wurden
vorbereiten kapitänin website wurden der
sitzt bereits auf einem tollen wetter
und auf der drehbaren platte so kann ich
ein bisschen einfacher arbeiten habe ich
den distrikt findet sich jetzt noch aus
der form heraus
es geht immer am besten mit einem
backform messer die dauer back folie
löste struktur einfach so weg und jetzt
habe ich hier ein bisschen
erdbeermarmelade ohne stückchen und die
ist auch fein passiert jetzt ein
bisschen erwärmt und die nehme ich
einfach im leben der beiden teig wirken
da könnt ihr jetzt es wäre nehmen oder
aprikosen zum beispiel nehmen kommt da
das schöne lockere bizkit drauf und den
trinke ich jetzt mit espresso ihr könnt
aber auch statt es so zum beispiel einen
likör nehmen oder auch beides einfach
mission
und jetzt setzt hier nochmal einen bug
herum denn die creme sind flüssiger und
muss erst reste im kühlschrank hat kann
sie auch warm und dann ist die creme
auch gleich so weit weg jetzt nur noch
lauwarm
da müsste auch wirklich sehr darauf
achten jetzt nämlich sahne
die könnt ihr übrigens auch mit wissen
seiner parkstreifen eignet sich auch gut
ich auch ein bisschen wasser zugegeben
vorhin beim steif schlagen denn zum
sitzen ein bisschen verrückt verhalten
das heißt so etwa 150 gramm für die tat
war am ende die restliche sahne
fröhliche 4 1 und setzte unter dampf
vorgelegt und ich zeige euch auch gleich
isoliert probe die sache steht jetzt
kühlen und so sie zwischen apropos
austeilt die masse wird richtig schön
fest jetzt natürlich noch ein bisschen
zu fest aber es kam mir auch die sahne
dazu die creme sitzt am anfang ein
bisschen flüssiger da muss schon
aufpassen da ist am arbeiten mit agar
agar schon viel einfacher kommt hier die
hälfte sein
dann kommen jetzt die löffelbiskuits mit
rein
[Musik]
jetzt kommt noch die restliche fülle
obendrauf
die torte stand jetzt über nacht kühl
und ich möchte euch jetzt noch eine
weitere variante zeigen nämlich die
zubereitung mit agar die habe ich auch
bereits gestern gemacht es ist einfach
immer besser wenn solche torten wirklich
über nacht kühl stehen können und die
creme auch richtig schön fest wird bei
der zubereitung mit dem acker ist es
genau wird dass die milch eier massa auf
dem herd zubereitet wird aber das ak mit
dem wasser in einen separaten topf zwei
minuten lang auf gekocht wird und
anschließend wird die masse dann in die
eier nimmt mache eingerührt und dann wie
gewohnt weiter verarbeitet die torte
weise über nacht im kühlschrank und
jetzt so richtig schön fest jetzt kann
ich sie fährt dekorieren er soll jetzt
einfach mindestens vier bis sechs
stunden aber am besten ist wenn man über
nacht kühlen
ich hatte zwar peter kuvertüre und zwar
habe ich die nach der impfung tode
temperiert das heißt zwei drittel
dekorateure habe ich über einem warmen
aber nicht kochenden wasserbad erwärmt
und dann das restliche drittel
eingerührt mit einem stückchen kokosfett
und so habe ich jetzt das schöne
glänzende kuvertüre zug einen
grauschleier bekommt wenn sie abkühlt
npd arrest viel dafür bist wird einfach
damit einstreichen und damit gleich die
trotz
dekorieren
löffelbiskuits mit der kubatur habe ich
gerade kurz im kühlschrank gelagert sind
wenn ich erst einmal den tortenring und
wenn er nicht möchte dass die löffel
bizkit oben stimmen dann sollte ich dir
die erste schicht creme machen lassen
bis tricks drauf dann kurz in den
kühlschrank und dann die zweite schicht
lassen bis die creme aber mir einfach
noch ein bisschen flüssig aber zum
schluss gar nicht schlimm ich nehme
jetzt die sahne und streicher von noch
ein bisschen was an den rand wird das
einfach auf der map pack boden damit
bedeckt ist
die restliche sahne völlig jetzt in
einen spritzbeutel und abkühle dran und
da ich jetzt auch spritzen werde ist es
auch ganz gut dass sie eben am vortrag
wenn die sauna zubereitet wird
vanoc hat mit einem wird einfach damit
die samische und standfest bleibt und
sahne las ich kurz da nehm jetzt erst
einmal an gesplittert und die habe ich
jetzt in einer pfanne ohne fett geröstet
und sie jetzt ganz gut abkühlen lassen
und die kommen jetzt hier an den rand
[Musik]
wieder spritzt oder spritze ich jetzt
einfach ein paar tupfer an den rand
retorte
und dann könnt ihr die karte mit den
löffel biscuit mit der übrigen sahne und
mit dem mantel splittern auf dekorieren
die torte lässt sich dann übrigens ganz
einfach hoch nehmen da ich hier den
mittag wurden drin gehabt und so kann
ich sie jetzt von der tortenplatte aus
ihrem torten retter auf diese schöne
trocken platte übersetzen
dafür einfach übertragen sind wurden
lösen und wieder sehen
jetzt können wir die karte probieren und
ich glaube den monat ist gerade fleißig
dabei herauszufinden warum diese torte
maler kraftorte genannt wird
ich hab so viel wissen mir manchmal
springt einfach doch trauen gegen
praktisch anrufe und google moratti war
das noch mal welche so ein großes stück
abschneiden
ja bitte habe ballack auf also ist es
eine österreichische pr und zwar die
wurde nach malakhov genannt alles war
eine festung der russische festung und
der französische marschall
ich weiß nicht wer heißt sie haben
danach irgendwann name ist genau wie ich
sage ich nur empfehlen heißt aber nicht
verlassen hatte und wie ich kann die
navi französischen namen aussprechen
zeigt ich gesagt okay
der schacht er hat eine russische
festung gestürmt malakhov und zu seinem
namen
zu seinen ehren wurde stefanie malakhovs
von beginn an sehr gut aber im fernsehen
ist es ja egal warum sie so heiß wie sie
gemacht wir nicht das war ein franzose
russische festung gestürmt ist aber in
österreich ist aber jedenfalls dass du
jetzt probiere liebe österreich ich
wusste gefällt uns und ist er wirklich
in verschiedenen variationen also jeder
macht der anlass manche machen damit
noch mehr geschichten
viele machen die leute mit
löffelbiskuits gar nicht erst selber
aber das ist seine selbstgemachten
löffelbiskuits und einfach genial
jahren bedenklich mehr wenn man sich
sowieso die mühe macht und ein biskuit
zusammenrührt kann man auch einfach
postpalast witz einfach auf spritzen sie
ganz schnell ganz ehrlich war berechtigt
leicht muffig oder liebe österreicher
ich hab echt was drauf ist lecker
richtig lustig leicht nicht zu süßen
gehört mir und der zeit und der boden
und die bisher bis maine startbahn werde
noch weiter zu fassen so einfach ein
paar etwas zu erreichen
ja soll ich tun finde ich auch ja aber
ich werde das ist wirklich eine richtig
tolle sonntags torte
vor allem können wir damit eure l haben
eure großeltern beeindruckend und ich
finde sie wirklich super lecker vor
allem minis die samstags zubereitet
könnt ihr sie am sonntag einfach
wirklich zum zusammenwachsen was kaffee
und kuchen und kaffee klatsch verwehren
also etwa dass die österreichische
stoppen weil wir meinen franzose eine
russische verfassung gestimmt hat war ja
und die türken macht macht und hätte
schon lange moralische gemacht jetzt
erst einmal eine multikulti torte falls
ihr das rezept gerne nachmachen möchte
dann schaut auf release - blog.de das
steht noch mal alles ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und kleine box ich hab mich
die fans bestimmt sondern die hauptstadt
zerstört
kamera aus der fläche
nein mach du auch machst du aus dem haus
[Musik]